donc il célèbre fable de la fontaine
réinterprétée par une artiste du centre
de musique baroque de versailles c'est
l'essence même du projet la fontaine en
scène lancé en octobre 2019 à la
verrière au programme pour les habitants
vers hyérois et trappistes deux ans
d'ateliers de rencontres artistiques
autour de la redécouverte des célèbres
fables mais le confinement a mis un coup
d'arrêt à la cinquantaine d'ateliers
pratiques prévu entre mars et mai pour
maintenir le lien entre les stagiaires
de l'école de la deuxième chance attrapé
l'univers de la fontaine le projet a dû
se réinventer le rat de vue l'europe des
shows autrefois le rat des villes invite
alors à deschamps d'une façon fort
civile à des reliefs de rto là les
artistes ont créé toute une vidéo
incitant les jeunes à se mettre en scène
en leur donnant des exercices très très
créatif
aussi durant le confinement l'équipe
artistique de la fontaine en scène a
posté une dizaine de vidéos elle à la
criée pas laisser la fournissent à vrai
dire la priant de du triptyque quelques
grains pour subsister jusqu'à la saison
pour l'instant les ateliers les
rencontres ne peuvent toujours pas
reprendre mais le cmbv à quelques pistes
pour que le projet puisse se poursuivre
qu'on a proposé à l'école des hemmes
chance de mettre à disposition certains
de nos locaux sont des personnes qui
permet de faire des tout petits groupes
se respecter la distance à la
distanciation fini et ensuite bien sûr
on se projette en septembre en espérant
alors quand un rythme hebdomadaire parce
que c'est vraiment ce qui est souhaité
la vidéo va continuer à être largement
utilisé comme outil
le projet doit prendre fin en 2021 année
où l'on fêtera le 400e anniversaire de
la naissance de la fontaine
[Musique]